nous vous en parlions déjà hier le
député du loir et cher guillaume
pelletier va devoir s'expliquer sur
l'utilisation de ses assistants
parlementaires et régionaux selon
mediapart l'élu aurait utilisé du
personnel payé avec de l'argent public
pour servir ses propres intérêts lui
parle de machination politique
explications et décryptage dans ce
reportage de florent clavel
avec la justice politique quand on est
de droite 100% de chances d'être
poursuivi par un procureur avant une
élection c'est par ce tweet accusateurs
que guillaume pelletier a réagi hier à
l' enquête ouverte contre lui par le
parquet de blois une enquête pour
détournement de fonds publics après la
publication d'un article de mediapart en
novembre dernier des faits présumés que
conteste l'avocat du député du
loir-et-cher longuet d'avoir une enquête
a démontré écoutez défaut dans des mois
ou des années peut-être milliards sera
condamné pour diffamation et le
procureur remplira son dossier et or
guillaume buffet députée et l'air mais
aussi président du groupe udc à la
région centre val de loire de 2015 2021
guillaume pelletier disposait à ce titre
de collaborateur problème selon
mediapart qui il les aurait en partie
employé à des fins privées notamment
pour son micro-parti les amis de
guillaume pelletier chargée de récolter
des dons l'association organise divers
événements exemple la traditionnelle
fête de la violette ou la venue de
nicolas sarkozy en sologne
il faut bien trouver nos racines
concerné au premier chef par cette
affaire la région centre val de loire va
se porter partie civile
6 et hamdi par l'enquêté par la décision
de justice que les moyens n'ont pas été
utilisés aux fins prévues aux fins
inscrite dans notre règlement alors la
région doit nécessairement faire valoir
son droit
reste à trois mois de la présidentielle
ces accusations de déstabilisation
politique porté par le nouveau porte
parole d'eric zemmour une justice aux
ordres qui voudraient nuire à la
campagne du candidat d'extrême droite
des accusations balayées par le
procureur de la république de blois je
suis instrumentalisé par personne je
fais mon métier il est absolument pas
dans ma volonté d' interférer en quoi
que ce soit sur un processus
démocratique je respecte
mais il m'appartient aussi de mener des
enquêtes dès lors que des éléments sont
portés à ma connaissance et qui peuvent
constituer une infraction confiée à la
division économique et financière de la
section de recherches d'orléans
l'enquète sur guillaume pepy va durer
plusieurs mois ensuite seulement le
procureur décidera si le vice-président
du parti reconquête doit être poursuivi